hello everyone and welcome to today's
broadcast a keynote presentation
tracking the resist own in one health
surveillance it is presented by Patrick
McDermott PhD director of the National
antimicrobial resistance monitoring
system at the office of research in the
Center for Veterinary Medicine at the
FDA I am Judy O'Rourke of lab roots and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by
labyrinth lab Rhodes is the leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars before we begin I'd like to
remind everyone this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want anytime you want
during the presentation just click on
the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen type your
questions into the drop down box it
appears on the screen and click on the
send button our speaker will respond to
your questions via email if you have
trouble seeing or hearing a presentation
just click on the ask a question box to
let us know you're having a problem this
presentation means educational and thus
offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming dr.
McDermott I will now turn the
presentation over to him thank you very
much and welcome everybody it's a
privilege to be participating in this
conference remotely and to take
advantage of the opportunity lab revised
for researchers in the field to share
some of the latest updates on their work
and including in that of course some of
the public health activities that I want
to talk to you about today in my
presentation on tracking the resistant
and one health surveillance so let us
begin then the resistant we are talking
of course of about a major public health
challenge facing the world today which
is antibiotic resistance or
antimicrobial resistance and it's an
issue that
long been recognized as an impending
difficulty and is now ranked among the
top three threats to global health and
it's a widespread problem it's a and and
this slide just happens to show some of
the popular press and articles from
scientific journals and others showing
the scope of the problem ranging in
everything from untreatable cases of
drug-resistant tuberculosis for example
where the last resort is reductive lung
surgery in cases where antibiotics are
completely impotent because of
multi-drug resistance there are medicine
cases of Neisseria gonorrhea in the US
and around the world that had become not
only resistant to antibiotics but more
invasive in pathogenic and so across the
scope of the public health sector and
around the world it is an issue and a
problem to various degrees but one
that's growing in in in is growing
internationally and has to be addressed
in an international manner in and part
of the way in which that does is through
the surveillance system and I think it's
it's true to say that the consensus is
fairly Universal that in order to combat
antibiotic resistance we need to combat
it in every environment in which
antibiotics are used and to assure that
those those uses are appropriate and
prudent and and tailored to specific
pathogens and optimized if you will in
the best way so that we preserve
antibiotics for future generations and
most of us don't have a full
appreciation of how things have changed
and I think it's useful to think back
for just a moment and and I have a quote
here from Louis Thomas when he describes
the early days of antibiotics in what
what has been called the Golden Age of
antibiotics and the impact it had on
practitioners at the time and this is an
excerpt from one of his books in the
early 80s and he says for most of the
infectious diseases there was nothing
that can be done beyond bed rest and
good nursing care
then came the explosive news of
sulfanilamide in the start of the real
revolution of Medicine
now remember the astonishment when the
first case of pneumococcal instruct the
cockle septicaemia were treated in
Boston in 1937 the phenomenon was almost
beyond belief there were more abundant
agents who would surely have died
without treatment improving within a
matter of hours feeling entirely well
within the next day we became convinced
overnight that nothing lay beyond the
reach of the future medicine was off and
running so you get a sense from the tone
of this just what a revolution these
medicines were when they became when it
became possible to use them in large
populations intrigue would have
previously been untreatable diseases now
here's a another quote from Margaret
Chan the wh our recent whu-oh director
to the g7 health ministers in 2015 they
chose by contrast where we've come since
1937 the rise of antimicrobial
resistance is a global health crisis she
says medicine is losing more and more
main stain mainstay antimicrobials as
pathogens develop resistance second line
treatments are less effective more
costly more toxic and sometimes
extremely difficult to administer many
are also in short supply superbugs hot
hospitals and intensive care units all
over the world
a few replacement products in the
pipeline the world is heading toward a
post-antibiotic era in which common
infections will once again kill so you
can get a sense of how we've come so far
after many decades of widespread
antibiotic use in human and veterinary
medicine and the sense of urgency that
this is placed upon governments around
the globe to try to grapple with this
problem and the new World Health
Organization is leading spearheading
this to their global action plan which
outlines a number of elements that
countries should incorporate into
national strategies to combat antibiotic
resistant bacteria the United States has
such a plan as well that was published
in March of 2015 where it says the US
will work domestically and
internationally to prevent detect and
control illness and deaths related to
infections caused by resistant bacteria
and it has five major goals in it and
these are just slow the emergence of
resistant bacteria and prevent the
spread of infections strengthen national
one health surveillance
for us to combat resistance and that'll
be the focus of our discussion today
advanced development and use of rapid
and innovative diagnostic tests
accelerate basic and applied research to
develop new drugs therapeutics and
vaccines and improve international
collaboration and capacity for control
surveillance in research and so these
are the five main prongs of our national
strategy and and what I want to talk to
you about today is is what we're doing
in terms of national one health
surveillance efforts to combat
resistance and how we're incorporating
into that the latest genomics
technologies to make those data more
valuable and and and give us a better
understanding of the nature of the
hazards in a one health surveillance
programs in terms of resistance so let
me define our terms and a little bit
further there so one health surveillance
is sort of a new description if you will
for what we used to call integrated
surveillance of antimicrobial resistance
and this refers to foodborne bacteria
specifically and it's integrated in the
sense that it involves the coordinated
sampling and testing of bacteria from
food animals from foods dry from those
animals and from clinically ill humans
and then the subsequent evaluation of
resistance trance throughout the food
animal production and supply chain using
harmonized methods and that's a
definition right from the WH o--'s
advisory group an integrated
surveillance surveillance of animal Co V
resistance now the one health twist to
this definition is to include the
environment and so the one health triad
is that healthy people healthy animals
and healthy environments are all collect
and to keep them that way requires
interdisciplinary approaches from the
scientific community this includes
everything from ecologists and
epidemiologists to molecular biologists
and economists and so just to take a
broader perspective on what health means
in in terms of ecosystems so the way
this is functions this type of
integrated or one health surveillance
system functions it's designed primarily
to understand
contain antibiotic resistance arising in
on the farm issue will include animal
production and to try to quantify how
much of that resistance moves through
the food supply and the burden of
resistant infections at places on the
human population and so a surveillance
system that does as well
does first go out and get baseline
information on what is the level of the
nature and the magnitude of resistance
and the major commodities that are part
of the local economy and so in the
United States that's mainly beef or
chicken and turkey and and then seafood
I think you would answer that as the
major protein sources derive from
production units for antibiotics or use
and so that baseline information that
you get and I'll tell you how we do that
in a moment is used to understand how
things change over time and that's a
really key feature is are things getting
better are they getting worse can we
measure trends and put some solid
analysis behind those trends to
determine when a problem has become when
this issue of resistance which is a
natural biological phenomenon is
evolving into a medical problem that
requires words and attention another
part of what this a good surveillance
system can do is attribution can we tell
for example in a case of human foodborne
illness if we have just the bacterial
isolated in our hand
can we tell it say the food supply is
absent or the patient doesn't remember
what they ate could we characterize that
organism and a way to know to attribute
it to its animal source and and use that
information to mitigate the problem and
then the next part of this wheel if in
going around this wheel here in the
middle of the slide after attribution is
how do we understand antimicrobial use
and its relationship to resistance and
it's not always straightforward in some
cases it can be very straightforward and
you can see rather direct relationships
for some drugs in some bacteria but it's
it's a complex issue and it's very
different from one organism to another
but a good system a good surveillance
system that can achieve this would have
good use data as well as good resistance
data and that's a very difficult data
set to to get get a hold of it and many
trees are struggling with that even now
but we continue United States through
our national plan to try to find optimal
ways to get that information so so we
can understand and refine the best
practices even while we may be looking
for alternatives to antimicrobials and
then as I mentioned the final the final
part of this wheel is the burden of
illness and and can we tell from the
human eye slits that were sampling in
this integrated fashion what is escaping
through from the farm through the food
supply or the environment and reaching
humans and so that's essentially how the
program works and in the United States
this program is called the national
antimicrobial resistance monitoring
system and it is integrated to
incorporate those three major categories
of bacteria or those three major
categories of source from which we
collect bacteria and monitor antibiotic
resistance and in our partnership with
in this partnership it consists of the
Centers for Disease Control the Food and
Drug Administration Center for
Veterinary Medicine the US Department of
Agriculture and what we what we do is we
collect the same essentially the same
bacterium we're focused mainly on the
most epidemiological important bacteria
for foodborne illness and that's
salmonella and campylobacter and so all
of those two organisms are isolated from
human population from retail meat
program retail meat surveillance and
from food animals that are presented for
slaughter at processing plants we put
these data together and the datasets get
fairly complicated but we put these data
together in a way that it tries to make
sense of the relationship I just
described in between drug use on the
farm or resistance arising on the farm
and moving through the food supply and
you can see from the sampling design
here which is in a very very much an
outline form that that on the food
animal side that USDA sampling and
entails it includes as I mentioned
before broiler chickens turkeys swine
and cattle and then on the FDA sampling
part of this surveillance system we have
the corresponding derived meats and then
CDC is looking at
cases from around the country and so
that we've been at this since 1996 so
NARMS is a fairly mature program it has
a great deal of data it's collected
isolate level information on several
hundred couple hundred thousand
organisms and publishes us together in
annual reports online which I would
invite you to to explore if you're
interested in the substance of the
program and some of the conclusions that
it has drawn over the years as well as
some of the impacts that interventions
designed interventions have made on
trends in resistance now I show a little
bit of history here because for those of
you who are in the public health arena
and are especially or maybe grappling
with this problem but in general just
trying to set up systems to measure
hazards in to human health in in any
environment what we learned in the
evolution of this program is that it's
often best and maybe only possible to
begin with ever whatever pre-existing
infrastructure might be at hand and so
what this slide shows is a history of an
arm sampling at CDC since it began in
1996 and I mentioned mainly
Campylobacter non typhoid or Salmonella
or target organisms but other bacteria
included in the program at CDC
especially and this just shows how you
know they began for example with non
typhoid or Salmonella in 96 getting
every tenth isolate from I think 14
states and currently they get every 20th
isolate from all 50 states so the
program has expanded over time as
resources were available and expanded
over and improved over time and
partnership with other programs and so
that's been one part of its success is
this ability to to to sort of take
advantage of the art of the possible if
you will in seeking new partnerships and
in taking advantage of other public
health infrastructures the USDA part of
it that is looking at the isolates from
animals began when norms began in 97
actually using the hasit program that
has up as you all surely know is part of
the surveillance
them that the food safety inspection
service uses to ensure the hygienic
quality of plants where animals are
processed so it's a it's a sampling
program where they get environmental and
samples and samples from animals and
look for the presence of salmonella
mainly and so though we relied on the
hasit system for many years but in 2013
late 2013 we set up a new system where
we got individual animal samples from
animals arriving at slaughter and you
can see in the new system
these are collected from the intestinal
contents it gets off it gets for the
major of NARMS target bacteria and is
now a nationally representative
randomized sampling of our food supply
and that's that's no small achievement
that's we have a very large production
system in the United States and to
achieve this on on the scale of the US
AG it's been a real improvement to norms
and the USDA has been instrumental in
making this happen and showing how you
know these type the partnerships between
the agencies has been so important and
then just really quickly on the food
side the third component again it began
at this part began in 2002 with just
five states and 2018 we're in 20 states
now and the map shows you know the
recent additions and there's a lot on
the slide but it shows our basic
approach where we're partnering with
States to go out every month and
purchase retail meats chicken turkey
beef and pork at grocery stores bring
them to the lab and isolate the bacteria
were interested in in in our national
resistance monitoring system and and
this just shows since 2016 we've nearly
tripled the number of samples that we
test every year around nineteen thousand
two hundred and twenty eighteen and I
mentioned Salmonella and Campylobacter
of the main target pathogens but we also
included coli and Enterococcus and it's
test that testing is done and a subset
of the retail meat States it's done at
all of the animal testing and that gives
us good information on antibiotic
resistance the agents that have activity
against gram-positive organisms as well
as having a more ubiquitous organism
like e.coli would that we can recover
from samples more frequently than
salmonella and so we don't lose we don't
lose resistance data in the Sam
negative samples if you will so that's
how the program stands today essentially
and it's collecting a lot of isolates
and and they're getting characterized
essentially using the same methods I
mentioned that the harmonization part is
key so we're using the same
antimicrobial susceptibility testing
methods which is broth micro dilution
methods that means that we get the
minimum inhibitory concentration of
antibiotic that inhibits the strain
that's the sort of standard clinical
approach to susceptibility in vitro
susceptibility testing quantitative
susceptibility testing so we're trying
to we use the same drug panels from the
same manufacturer that goes to all the
agencies doing the testing so we're
really in and we have all the quality
control in place to make sure that the
data are comparable and we rely on
external Quality Assurance to make sure
the data are comparable and we have done
this for quite a few years using
standard methods that have been common
to microbiology for ninety years I
suppose which is to take the meat sample
isolate the bacteria that we're
interested in and then characterize into
different levels of analysis based on on
technology that is affordable and gives
the sort of resolution of strain
characteristics that help us understand
that that will I showed you at the start
you know the baselines and how things
are spreading and and how we can how can
we attribute things to different sources
and that in classical microbiological
terms has been you know isolating in
pure culture doing biochemical tests the
sort of you are what you eat kind of
identification system looking at strain
types through zero typing or P fge and
then presenting this in an aggregated
fashion showing you know where the main
serotypes are coming from by commodity
and how resistance levels are changing
over time and and by resistance levels I
mean the particular M IC for that drug
and that bacteria combination that's
generally what we've reported and in
just the phenotypic data and then later
typically if we had the resources in
time we'd go back and do research
studies to see what the genes were or
maybe
do more refined typing with phage typing
or mlst or look for virulence factors in
certain stereotypes and and then try to
get those reports out in peer-reviewed
literature which is usually much later
than then the samples were collected and
so it made that it made those sorts of
data perhaps less valuable just because
of the delay and being able to generate
the information and this is a typical
image of how we would report data in our
national surveillance in the NARMS
program at the isolate level and this
shows the two enzyme PF GE patterns on
the left black boxes for all the drugs
where resistance was detected and then
some metadata around the sample
including when it went and where it was
collected in serotype and so on and so
that has been arms for many years and
and how our data have been reported for
many years and and it's changing now
dramatically with the advent of
affordable whole genome sequencing and
that's what I'd like to spend the rest
of my time touching on is how that data
set has really transformed how our
surveillance is done and the level of
detail that's been added to the
information set that we now have the
adding genotype to phenotype you know if
you think about it we've gone from 16
antibiotics on tested against the strain
to extracting from it the three million
base pairs of DNA and so we're trying to
find ways to combine this comprehensive
genetic information with this somewhat
limited but fairly good phenotypic
resistance data and so when we first got
deeply involved in sequencing we started
it in 2006 but it didn't really become
affordable till around 2011-12 when we
started more and more just sequencing
our isolates on a routine basis we
another set out to look at what the
genomic processes could supplant in
classical microbiology such as can we
extract stereotype from the genome can
we use supplant pfg II with other strain
typing methods based on DNA sequence
which obviously one can
can we what can we learn about
susceptibility from the genetic data but
all by itself right and what can that
add to our phenotype data and the rest
of the advantages of sequencing are
fairly obvious you know the piecemeal
PCR experiments to look for genes or
various profiles or other molecular
markers are now built into the into the
laboratory process this single
laboratory method so you get all of that
automatically when you do the genome and
so it's really changed and it's changed
the type of information we have and has
allowed us to drape the data in
different categories of traits that are
making the making us able to be much
more targeted in our response to growing
resistance problems and I hope to
demonstrate that here in a moment and so
the next slide so this is just a
schematic of the same thing so can we go
from susceptibility testing to the
genetic susceptibility testing and on
top of that can we
circumvent classical microbiology all
together with meta genomic samples of
resistance surveillance you know which
is to characterize the entire DNA
content of a complex biological sample
like a food animal intestine or like a
food product and get their resistance
genes that way and how how can we put
that into our processes for assessing
risks in the drug use environment and to
make several stories short it works
incredibly well we did Studies on the
major target organisms in arms to show
that phenotype that you can predict
resistance and strains very accurately
based on the presence of known
resistance genes and so these are just
some paper showing where we've done
those studies for salmonella
Campylobacter e.coli and Inter caucus
and we continue to work on these but I
summarized some of the studies in this
slide that it's includes the ones I just
showed you but others are doing this as
well it works very well for many
bacteria it works very well for micro
bacteria pneumococcus staph aureus and
this shows the correlation between the
present antibiotic
just clinical resistance in the presence
of known genes for these different
pathogens is you know 95 to 100% in most
cases in other words genotypic
susceptibility testing for predicting
resistances at least as good as
phenotypic testing so that was a little
bit surprising to some of us so now the
question is well what does that mean for
how we've always interpreted laboratory
data and there's different ways in which
bacteria are characterized as being
resistant in the United States the
clinical and laboratory standards
Institute CLS is a rather rich
definition of resistance and they say it
implies that isolates are not inhibited
by the usually achievable concentrations
of the agent with normal dosage
schedules and and or demonstrates on
diameters that fall in the range where
resistant mechanisms are likely and
clinical efficacy has not been reliably
shown so it's a combination of various
data sets before they want to categorize
something as resistant or susceptible or
intermediate as the other categories the
European Union Committee for
antimicrobial susceptibility testing
uses a term called epidemiological
cutoff values which says resistant is
whatever is not wild-type so if it's
outside the the distribution of
susceptible of the susceptible
population it's categorized as resistant
now they have some variations on that
what we've learned from the sequencing
data is that it seems reasonable to
propose another definition which we've
turned genotypic cutoff values and Greg
Tyson on our group has been working on
this and we've defined this as the
highest MSE of the population of
bacteria lacking resistant determinants
to a given drug so it's sort of the
genotypic wild-type distinction and it
has caused us in a way to sort of look
at the gene as the hazard if you will
we're more focused on the underlying
causes of resistance rather than just
the phenotypic testing and the
variability that goes with that
so does this this shows up just a very
basic schematic of how you would
determinate
a cutoff value based on genomics and you
can see on the top left of this
table the wildtype distribution and
shown in green bars in the histogram and
then in this case for quit alone
resistance the presence of mutations are
Q&R genes and then so in this case you
would set the genotypic cutoff value
right here at point oh six right then i
assume i see where black acquired traits
and this does help us understand now
data and and help hopefully resolve some
of the differences and and and maybe get
closer to harmonizing the ways we
interpret this information
internationally and so this table just
shows where for the drugs on our NARMS
panel the differences between the clsi
and the you caste or the absence of
breakpoints in some cases can be the
gaps can sort of be filled in now with
the GCV z-- based on two genomic data
alone so we've learned in sequencing
predicts resistance very well that it
helps us refine our categorization and
and it adds even more than that and and
so i want to tell you a little bit about
that next so now we've thought well okay
we can predict resistance can we predict
the actual mi see if it's you know point
or if it's one two four eight in this
serial dilution instead of whether or
not it's just as hit this threshold to
categorize it as resistant and the
answer to that is is seems to be yes or
at least in our preliminary studies are
very promising and this is a
collaboration we did with colleagues at
Argonne National Labs in the University
of Chicago Jim Davis is limb and this is
up on the web at today in its pre print
form and there's the cute the cute are
code here if you want to read it but
this essentially in this study we took
5,000 of our sequenced isolates where we
had phenotype data its susceptibility
data 16 antibiotics and basically used
in annex G boost machine learning model
to try to see if we could find signature
sequences associated specifically
associated with specific MI sees within
a one twofold dilution which is the
error range even in phenotypic testing
and the answer is it works just as well
to predict any IMI see is it does to
predict the resistant breakpoint and so
I highlighted in blue maybe the upshot
of this study is these models
Monsieur machine learning models are
capable of predicting susceptible and
resistant mi sees with no a priori
information about the underlying gene
content of the genomes it's stable over
time even as the trend lines change and
can be done with fairly small number of
sequenced bacteria and so this works on
going I don't know we don't know yet how
far this will be able we'll be able to
take this if the goal is to you know
move towards maybe one method it's going
to have to be useful to the clinician
who wants to know mi see sometimes so
that ongoing work is is promising but
there's much still to be done so I've
tried to show you how we see genomics
changing our historical way of doing
surveillance but you know there's other
things about it that are gonna be fairly
obvious to you but that are also really
powerful in trying to characterize
hazards resistant hazards in the food
supply and the the first part comes back
to my earlier slide where I said you
know that we automatically now in one
laboratory workflow get the genetic
content of an organism basically the
highest structural resolution of
individuating traits you can get from an
organism is its sequence of nucleotides
and so with that we can get down to the
details of recombination involved in the
accumulation of resistance on different
mobile DNA elements how they interact
with virulence and stereotyped factors
and so on and I just want to give you a
couple examples of work like that that's
come out of our NARMS laboratories and
the first one this goes back to 2007
where we did a sequencing project of
Salmonella and found a multi
drug-resistant plasma this ink a c2
plasma is shown on the left hand side
which is identical to a strain of your
sania passes that was recovered from a
child in Madagascar in 1997 ten years
earlier who had the plague and I that by
itself to me illustrates this one health
notion as a global one health notion you
know this these things do
spread far and wide and quickly if you
base it on the Sin City and the genetic
analysis and in this case this backbone
plasmid was 99% identical with this
Yersinia pestis plasmid and plasmids
widespread in the United States food
supply and infecting humans and you can
see around the border of this the
different accumulated resistance islands
and you know it's almost I tell people
it's like an archaeological dig on the
history of antibiotic development and it
starts with sulfonamide resistance in
the backbone the cell to gene and you
can go around the outer rim and this is
the Salmonella Nieuport strain from our
sequencing and see for Fanta call and
tetracycline resistance and streptomycin
resistance and then various amino
glycosides and cordon aramony compounds
sulfonamide mercury all piled up in this
plasmid and in the bottom right you see
something that's really interesting to
me is the blossom y2 gene which gives
ceftriaxone resistance very important
antibiotic and next to that a gene for a
gene called siggy one which gives
resistance to products used in the
processing plant to to decontaminate
carcasses and so you know we spend a lot
of time thinking about how antibiotic
use drives the resistance patterns in
our food supply but maybe it's also
processes in the plant and so this idea
of getting at new associations that
might be driving resistance is a real
eye-opener when you're trying to design
targeted mitigation strategies on the
right hand side is a study we did where
we essentially found a spike in
gentamicin resistant Campion and found
eight different gentamicin resistance
genes six which had never been seen
before in Campion which we would have
never seen by PCR and so it's just given
us the details that we didn't have
before on what's driving resistance
another great example of how genomics is
transforming surveillance and helping us
combat resistant bacterias you know it's
a portable permanent and interpretable
data set and so what that means is you
can go back in time when a new emergence
a new resistant gene emerges and see if
you have it in your country or your area
or your hospital and so
example of that was the MC r1 gene which
came with first reported in China in
2015 and right away people around the
world scrambled into their freezers and
into their databases and at the time we
had one hundred and fifty five thousand
bacterial genomes that we screened and
could say that that gene had not made it
to us and so we could inform the
practitioner community about that fact
and and that's very valuable and data
that you can now get quickly that we
couldn't have gotten before so it's a
major step forward and it only gets
better with time right another example
from NARMS where the genomic data is has
helped in us understand the phenotypic
trends was a case with Salmonella Dublin
from humans and cattles was showing
increased resistance to SEP tracks and a
decreased susceptibility to
ciprofloxacin and it was a problem it's
a this is a serial type that is common
in cattle and causes disease in cattle
and a burden to the industry it's fairly
rare in humans but it's very virulent in
humans and and now we can see more why
that's the case on a reaching basis and
this is a schematic of the sequencing
from these strains showing that there
are 15 different pathogenicity islands
and Salmonella Dublin some are some of
the pathogenesis EGS are piled up on
recombined plasmids that are also having
antibiotic resistance genes on them and
so you can see in the genetics a
reflection of the pathogenesis
pathogenic processes and infected
patients and I think people are looking
to this is to give sort of more refined
hazard analysis if you will more refined
approach to the types of the subtypes of
organisms from different environments
and and there's a lot of work going on
right now between the NARMS partners and
and NIH to try to refine these
categories of virulence gene content and
plasmid types and so on - so that this
type of more refined work can be done
let me move on I mentioned metagenomics
a little bit metagenomics is essentially
as to the process of determining the DNA
sequence of a complex by Allah
single sample without usually without
culturing some people there are some
modifications to the different
approaches but basic question is how do
we get beyond the four bacteria that we
targeted norms to get to the entire
resistant and the way to do that is to
get to the entire meta-genome where you
can and and we have taken this
nationally-representative randomized
surveillance of the food animal supply
in the United States and have kept for
the last few years every one of those
samples and we are reducing them down to
their DNA constituents and to the extent
that we can determining how determining
the different resistance profiles
associated with different food animal
types and so this works being done by
Daniel Tennessee and in our labs at CBM
for the norms purposes and we're
starting to make progress or we can you
know associate certain genes with
certain specific animal origins so that
that's going to a lot of people see that
as you know the next phase in genomics
or surveillance for infectious diseases
moving on quickly here I just want to
say so we each year NARMS produces a lot
of data and we've added to it a lot more
data we currently have Salmonella from
12 different sources which we compared
to those from humans and then we grapple
with how to put all this together in a
comprehensive way that includes the
genomic information and and I'd invite
you again to you know Google NARMS
integrated report if you like to go and
see our latest attempts to do this and
this is ongoing work but we're starting
to weep the genetic data now into the
phenotypic data and then if it's best we
can get this up to more real-time
reporting and that that's our goal our
goal is that we would have within a
matter of weeks at the most from primary
isolation to sequence in the public
domain for sharing globally with with
people and and to try to create
something like a weather map of
resistance if you will in a in a one
health framework and so at this point
I'm gonna just go through a couple
screenshots of some slides just to show
very basic ways in which we've done this
so far in arms and and as I said I would
invite you to go look on your own to see
how much of its valuable and frankly to
give us feedback but we've started to
add to the phenotypic timelines it's
shown in this slide the G how the genes
change over time and it's a little bit
difficult to see this in screenshots but
if you go online you can you can you can
mouse over these different data points
and get a better feel for the
information and that's just in the norms
reports we've since we know we can
predict resistance from the genome we
can apply resistance genotype to any
string deposited in the NCBI database
and we've started to do that as well and
so now we don't really have to have
phenotype to make really sound decisions
and conclusions about the nature of
resistance and isolates from different
sources and so we've developed a tool
and Heather Tabas has put it put this up
on the web we've developed a tool called
root system tracker which right now has
salmonella Campylobacter and e.coli in
it that the NARMS bacterial bay
essentially allows you to start with
resistance if you're interested in
resistance say in the case of beta
lactam resistance and you can go and
look at isolates from the US and non-us
sources and we're going to make this
better but you can pick any gene you
like in the top right here once you
selected a phenotype that you're
interested in and you can go and see if
you've seen this gene saying for the
first time in your country you can now
go in here and say well who else has
seen it and how far has it spread and
where might I expect it to be coming
from if it's entered into our area here
and I'm trying to find pick one here
bossy my and and drill down and and I'm
not going to spend a lot of time here
because I don't have much time and I and
it but it's really very powerful how we
can now in as much as we can share data
we can share vital information on the on
traits that are public health importance
and we've set this up so that if you
drill down to a resistance gene say for
example that you're interested in
isolate you can click
the isolate and go right to ncbi's
pathogen detection portal where we sort
of hand off the whole process to NCBI
and or let me maybe I should say it this
way the resistant tracker sits on top of
the NCBI data and so you can through the
strain you're interested in go to the
tools at NCBI and see where it fits on
the phylogenetic tree within NCBI and so
you can see if your sample there or your
isolate that you've just picked up in
your surveillance system has been those
been sequenced and uploaded how it
aligns with other products like pet food
or an environmental sample from Assam or
any of a number of things and then
attended to that all the other NCBI
tools at your disposal within within
that website and then lastly very
quickly we're trying to make it more
valuable by refining the categories in
the metadata the metadata can be quite
complex at NCBI as you know and we're
reliant on what other people submit but
there's work going on to to refine these
and so that you can you can look at
specific genes by general category and
do the same sorts of drilling down into
source and time of appearance and things
of that nature so that you can have
whatever context is available in the
National repositories of genetic
information to help you understand any
emergent resistant problem related to
the food agricultural chain so I know
that's a kind of a quick flyover of some
of the online tools they're much more
interesting to interact with live much
more interesting than the slides and I
as I said I would encourage you to go
there and see now and give us feedback
on on how we might do what we do better
and make these information more valuable
to more people one way we're trying to
do that in the norms program is is
through a commitment to open and
transparent and public data sharing and
we do that through a tool we call norms
now and it's it's basically the
repository of all of our isolate level
data nearly 200 thousand entries of
isolate level data for salmonella
Campylobacter and e.coli and Inter
caucus collected since night
96 I mentioned Salmonella from all the
different food sources and has extensive
metadata including mi C's 216
antibiotics the whole genome sequencing
data is going up on into NCBI we're
trying to link it to our NARMS now
spreadsheet so you can download the
entire program essentially and take
advantage of the data for your own
research or public health purposes and
as I mentioned before the goal is to
make this as real-time as possible as
soon as we can and we hope we can do
that in the 2018-2019 year time period
so that's a lot in a little bit of a
time and I really did entirely do
justice to every element I wanted to try
and cover today but I wanted to wrap up
with maybe a few general thoughts and
thoughts about the future and how
genomics is making one health
surveillance a more realistic approach
to to infectious disease and combating
resistant bacteria I say in here one
health one method I mean we're not there
yet but the promise of genomics is is
really encouraging and the technique
technology is very powerful and has
become very affordable and some of the
new technology on the horizon is really
quite astonishing and I think it's going
to very very rapidly continue to become
a reaching laboratory process in in
clinics and hospitals and public health
agencies worldwide as I mentioned before
the main advantage that gives you the
highest practical resolution of
individuating structural traits you can
get from an organism
I think that's safe to say and members
of an ecosystem if you're looking at
metagenomics we've demonstrated that
it's an accurate prediction of clinical
resistance and perhaps mi see at least
in Salmonella so far in another study on
Klebsiella I think showing the same
ability to predict them I see it reveals
a resistance to compounds we've not
historically tested such as
disinfectants and heavy metals and other
potential drivers of resistance which
which our efforts are incomplete if we
don't if we don't have all that
knowledge it allows deep surveillance
into previously hidden Association so
it's just go resistance with plasmids
and virulence and it
just a cataloging all the different
mobile DNA elements immediate the spread
of resistance is now become very
automatic in our processes source
attribution for more precise
intervention I didn't show the research
we've done on that but we've done a few
preliminary studies where we've
identified some surface structures in
typhimurium that seem to be specific for
the animal source even though the
stereotype is not so we continue to work
on that very powerfully it gives
retrospective resistance surveillance
metagenomics are developing to allow us
to escape limitations on whole genome
and get us to metagenomic surveillance
and because of the dropping costs and
the fact that you don't have to buy two
enzymes for PF GE and run pfg
instrumentation and all the expense and
specialized reagents and instrumentation
that went with the old classical
approach this should free up resources
to look farther and fewer with into
environments like wild animal
populations look at animal feed and its
role in pet foods and other sources
companion animals and other exposure
pathways including a refined sampling
design for environmental testing taken
together this should give us a much
clearer picture of the global resistance
emergence and spread and greater
confidence in our public health
decision-making and colleague of mine
Eric Brown at FDA likes to show this
comparison of what the transition and
technology is meant to our understanding
and and he uses the staring at the night
sky as an analogy where we've gone from
pathogen plating as a sort of stargazing
to the biochemical speciation followed
by phenotypic subtyping and then
genotypic subtyping and now the Hubble
telescope which gives us this
high-resolution of genomics and and has
really made the datasets so much more
valuable well so where do we go from
here if we have this technology and I
mentioned some of this but a one health
framework ought to be looking at food
animal pathogens and not just the sonic
bacteria that are reaching humans
through the food supply because we want
healthy animals obviously as well as
healthy people for a healthy environment
can we look on farm to get a better
understanding of the what's changing
over time and specific drug use
environments its companion animal
surveillance what you know we don't
fully understand the contribution of
resistance it comes from our pets but we
do understand that we share their
microbiome and quite rapidly once we
bring a new pet home so there there's
reasonable grounds for looking there in
our pets where antibiotics are also used
in all antibiotics essentially or used
in pets so that's an important element I
mentioned it can you develop microbiome
methods but we need to also in all of
this processes things are changing so
rapidly as work in partnership across
federal state research laboratories
universities all those with common
interests in infectious diseases frankly
and to try to find out ways where the
data sharing processes are optimal and
our interpretation of them result in a
common language for a common approach to
combating resistance
it's Impala it's not possible to
acknowledge everybody in the program but
NARMS is a large program and with a lot
of dedicated people in all 50 states and
at CDC USDA and FDA and some of them are
mentioned here and I just want to wrap
up by saying that you know working with
NCBI to incorporate the genomics part
and with our colleagues at FDA and is
really pushing arms forward and we
continue to try to exploit these
genomics technologies to make this
program as consequential and meet our
mission to protect public health at FDA
and USDA and at CDC and with that I
thank you for tuning in today I hope
this has been interesting to most of you
perhaps and and the data said in the
public domain at least is there for your
perusal and exploitation and we'll
continue to try to keep putting data out
there for everyone to take advantage of
in and to use for public health purposes
and with that I thank you very much
thank you dr. McDermott's about
formative presentation we will now start
the Q&A portion of the webinar and we'll
address some of the most commonly asked
questions by our viewers if you have any
questions you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question
drop-down box located on the far left of
your presentation window type your
question into the box it appears on your
screen and click the send button or
speaker will follow up with your
questions via email let's get started
our first question is how will whole
genome sequencing change the
surveillance design that's a good
question and that's something that we
are grappling with and many others are
grappling with and we are working with
our counterparts in the European Union
right now in those discussions because
if you can predict from the genome the
presence of known genes with a great
degree of certainty and confidence
what type of phenotyping what do we be
doing then how should we be doing it
differently and I can give you a quick
example so we have streptomycin on our
antibiotic surveillance plate for
Salmonella it's not a drug used to treat
Salmonella but it it had been
incorporated historically because it
serves as a good marker for a resistance
pattern that was associated with a
specific strain type of Salmonella
called DT 104
so it had resistance to five drugs
including streptomycin so there is a
marker to help pre screen for this
strain well if you can glean that from
the genome we don't need to do that
phenotypic testing in all likelihood so
that raises a lot of possibilities we
have limited real estate on this typing
panel for MSE testing so we're talking
about new drugs to put on there like
co-list even though hadn't seen the
mobled gene we should be looking for it
and to put or advanced antibiotics on
there but I expect it will evolve over
time depending on how the studies play
out I'm predicting in mice it will
evolve over time and we haven't really
come to terms of what it look like a few
years from now but we hope to work it
out in lockstep with our counterparts
and he knew as I mentioned so that we
updated we can compare him and no gaps
in the
so there are discussions we can
understand the resistance situation so
it's a it's a good question and a hard
question and one that's hard to predict
but it surely will impact how we've done
things historically in terms of messages
thank you for that next one is you
mentioned the norms now website where
all the norms isolate level data are
made public are other countries making
similar data public so comparisons can
be made that's a very good question and
that's a complicated one so there's
their route there are laws in different
countries that preclude some of that
data sharing an impact in the United
States too so it's it can be state level
differences and what type types of data
from a patient can be put in the public
domain and so some countries have laws
against that they preclude them from
doing so and some of them are being a
redress in terms of the antibiotic
resistance you know nice to see you know
if there are ways that public that
privacy can be protected and so they can
be shared so it's a complicated problem
because they're legal issues tangled up
with it but to the extent possible I I
think everyone wants to put that
information out there
so that we can all have the same weather
map of resistance if you well so that we
can all have our eyes on the same
hazards and work in a coordinated
fashion to try to try to deal with them
so that that's going to it's going to
take some time to to expand the number
of countries who are able to share data
in real time in the public domain but I
think that the trend is towards that
sort of openness so that's a very
welcome thing thank you we have time for
one more question
given that the technology has become
affordable and widespread so quickly
what do you see happening in the next
few years yes well I think in terms of
infectious disease science which is what
we're focused on here I mean that not
even to mention just genomics with
individuals and the rapid progress
that's really quite astonishing you know
they're talking of having an app and
phone that has your genome when you go
to your doctor I mean those sorts of
things are remarkable in and of
themselves I think in terms of
infectious disease science and use of
genomics I really do see very quickly
that it will become a desktop instrument
like so many desktops instruments in a
in a hospital lab or in a physician's
office that will pluck out of that the
pathogenic organism the essential
information for the physician to apply
proper treatment and for public health
officials to say interrupted outbreak if
there's one going on so I see rapid
real-time Diagnostics coming out of this
that are going to greatly accelerate
patient care one of the challenges with
it is though how do we keep the data
right sometimes these instruments have
you know sort of done with the sample
and throw away the information but the
data so I know some people are concerned
about warehousing this information was a
public health good but but it's going to
be generate it's going to continue to
accelerate in the pace at which it's
being generated and and trying to
grapple with the information is as big a
challenge as generating it but I think
it's just what we're going to see it
become a reaching common thing that he's
going to become there's already become
very affordable and and it's becoming a
data management issue as much as
anything so I I think the trajectory is
very positive in terms of availability
the technology being available in
widespread and that's always that's only
a good thing because of the amount of
information you glean from the technique
thank you for that I would like to once
again thank dr. McDermott for his
presentation I would also like to thank
lab roots for making today's educational
webcast possible before we go I want to
let everyone know that today's webcast
will be available for on-demand viewing
through December 13th 2018 you will
receive an email from lab roots letting
you know when this webcast will be
available for replay please share that
announcement with your colleagues who
may have missed today's event that is
all for now thank you for joining us we
hope
to see you again soon bye